>> LIZZO, YOU'RE GOING TO KILL
AT HOSTING THIS WEEK.
>> I KNOW, LIKE, HOSTING?
I THINK I CAN HANDLE THAT.
[ TALKING OVER EACH OTHER ]
>> I'D SAY SO.
>> IT'S JUST LIKE, THE WHOLE
MUSICAL GUEST THING THAT I'M
STRESSED OUT ABOUT.
I MEAN, TWO NEW SONGS?
[ LAUGHTER ]
I DON'T HAVE THOSE.
[ TALKING OVER EACH OTHER ]
I'M NOT JOKING.
>> WHAT -- WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> I GOT WRITER'S BLOCK.
>> WHAT?
>> CAN YOU WRITE ME A NEW SONG?
>> NO.
>> I'M GONNA NEED YOU TO WRITE
ME A NEW SONG.
>> WE CAN'T.
>> NEW SONG NOW, BITCH.
>> NOT GONNA HAPPEN.
>> GO.
♪ GIRL YOU ALWAYS
LEAVE ME ON READ ♪
♪ BROTHER
YOU LEAVE ME ALL BLUE ♪
♪ YOU THE BABY GIRL
YOU LOOK LIKE MY DAD ♪
>> WHAT THE HELL?
>> COME ON.
>> WE'RE -- WE'RE NOT SONG
WRITERS.
>> YOU SOUND HURT.
>> MAYBE IT'S MORE REAL.
MAYBE IT'S LIKE --
♪ I JUST GOT A HAIRCUT ♪
♪ I FEEL LIKE YOU CAN SEE
TOO MUCH OF MY FACE ♪
♪ TOO MUCH OF HIS FACE ♪
>> ARE YOU FEELING VULNERABLE?
>> NO, I WRITE SONGS ABOUT
FEELING CONFIDENT.
I NEED Y'ALL TO WRITE A BLACK
WOMAN ANTHEM.
>> ARE WE THE GUYS TO DO THAT?
>> WE CAN MAYBE WRITE A WHITE
MAN ANTHEM?
>> OH, YEAH, LIKE AN ANTHEM FOR
WHITE MEN.
>> OH, THAT'S --
>> ACTUALLY --
>> HEY LIZZO, GONNA NEED YOU
DOWNSTAIRS IN TEN TO REHEARSE
THOSE NEW SONGS.
CAN'T WAIT TO HEAR 'EM.
>> YOU KNOW I GOT THOSE BANGERS.
>> ALL RIGHT!
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> WE GOT TEN MINUTES, I NEED A
SONG.
YOU!
SEXY DADDY, COME ON.
>> SEXY?
SEXY --
>> SONG, NOW.
♪ I GOT MY BLUE JEANS ON
AND A BOTTLE OF JACK ♪
>> OKAY.
LET'S TRY CALL ON --
♪ I WOKE UP FEELING -- ♪
♪ ANXIOUS ♪
>> OH!
>> PLEASE, -- OUR SKETCH!
>> HEY, WE'RE ALMOST READY FOR
YOU.
AND BY THE WAY, IF THOSE NEW
SONGS AREN'T GOOD, I'M GONNA
KILL YOU.
>> HE CAN DO THAT?
>> HE'S DONE IT BEFORE.
>> SONGS, NOW, GO!
♪ I WOKE UP THIS MORNING ♪
>> THAT'S THE "SOPRANOS" THEME
SONG.
>> DAMN IT.
>> UH --
♪ WHY MEN GREAT
'TIL THEY GOTTA BE GREAT ♪
>> I ALREADY WROTE THAT ONE.
♪ MY GIRLFRIEND DRESSED
LIKE SPONGEBOB ♪
[ TALKING OVER EACH OTHER ]
>> YOU HAVE A GIRLFRIEND?
>> DO YOU HAVE, LIKE, A CRUSH ON
MARTIN?
>> WHAT IS GOING ON WITH YOU
TWO?
>> THIS ISN'T WORKING.
>> WE'RE TRYING SO HARD TO MAKE
A SONG FOR YOU.
♪♪
>> BUT WE CAN'T.
>> GUESS I GOTTA GO GET KILLED
BY ANDREW DISMUKES.
>> I'M SO SORRY, LIZZO.
>> BUT BEFORE I GO, PITCH ME
ANOTHER AMAZING SKETCH IDEA YOU
GUYS GOT.
♪♪
>> WELL, IT'S GOING TO SOUND
STUPID NOW, BUT --
IT'S CALLED "HORNY ZOOKEEPER."
♪♪
IT'S ABOUT A ZOOKEEPER WHO'S A
LITTLE HORNY.
I DON'T KNOW.
IT'S DUMB.
♪♪
>> NO, I LIKE THIS.
>> WAIT, WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
>> YEAH, THIS IS A GREAT SONG.
[ INDISCERNIBLE ]
♪ THE BEDROOM
IS MY PETTING ZOO ♪
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> OH, MY GOD, IT'S HAPPENING.
♪ SAID THE BEDROOM
IS MY PETTING ZOO ♪
♪ LITTLE MAMA ♪
♪ I GOT --
AND YOU'RE MY LLAMA LLAMA ♪
♪ GONNA SET YOU ON MY LAP
LIKE A DUCK
THAT'S THE PLAN ♪
♪ THEN I MAKE YOU EAT
A QUARTER WITH THE SEEDS
OUT THE PALM OF MY HAND ♪
♪ 'CAUSE I'M A
HORNY ZOOKEEPER ♪
♪ YOU KNOW THAT I'M A
HORNY HORNY HORNY ZOOKEEPER ♪
♪ PERIOD ♪
>> WOW.
>> OH, MY GOSH.
>> I DON'T THINK YOU SHOULD DO
THAT ON THE SHOW.